you
boom is where you want to be if you want
to hop in let's do it there are only 16
so far 12
seconds to go if you would like to play
you know where to go all right more
people are jumping in and we are ready
to go
who the sirens are going on here those
in the background okay
let's go a day for
gonna get in b5 okay
most certainly not playing this correct
I probably should have captured their
first try and maybe make this dark
square bishop of beasts can we do that
take with the rook
maybe make it difficult for that night
to develop and I want to take here just
yet let's go back take care I want to I
want to attack this is a blunder because
I could take here and then here I'm
thinking this is a slower game and still
I still have work to do let's push here
and then push again I want to glue these
two and yeah like this here ready to
take I could take here this glue that
Bishop in and then mop up this pawn no
back ranks just in case
and let's get the rooks off okay this
one should be cleaned from here
okay back to tournament land
okay and there are many more who have
jumped on in there there are 58 players
59
let's see we get okay how about how
about d6 this Oh oh I think there was a
shot already
I miss played the beginning hmm okay
I'll come back over here you have no
business being over on b6
what are you doing exactly this was
worth considering as well
I don't want to do this they didn't
commit their King on the kingside yet
they might go Queen side and then if
launched upon okay not now
how do we want to take probably with a
knight it's an improvement now let's
let's get the DAR square bishops off
tough guy right here
take with the night
discoveries 9 c4 9 c4 I can't play Queen
takes B oh this is running right into
discovery zone
getting a lot of material I'm having a
tough time
moving a piece clean if you haven't
realized it's taking me multiple tries
to be successful with moving the pieces
I want to take a bunch take a bunch
I guess we'll take here make sure that
f6 is not going to happen next and I can
always swing my queen back to help
defend if needed
[Music]
am I not taking hungie - I don't know
pigs men we have a lot of pigs around on
the second
they're hungry the major pieces are
hungry when on the opponent's
second-ranked
hungry for pawns let's try b3 oh this is
a prize it's a big gap on this square
what's this Knight gonna do he's going
to have a tough time think
okay I'm going to chase them away put
them in the corner
break this pin it's not quite in the
corner
maybe I should have waited till castle
then the knight couldn't go here let's
go here now what's this knight doing
I would like any light-square bishop
exchange in fact what are both Knights
doing they're having a tough day I don't
want to take we'll go towards the center
okay this is the best piece
let's cancel it out oh let's drop my
night mi night okay okay I dodged a
bullet
I'm very thankful to have this night
around
I'm on this guy I want to castle by hand
throw my king on G to keep my rook here
oh they're allowing this why
well I think they had a night here if I
took the bishop so now I think with this
sequence I'm winning some material they
have night here
what are weird very ancient here here
I think they saved the peace by taking
here first okay not this sequence I
think that one move earlier and I'm in
some trouble okay now now I could take
here I'm on the rook I missed that
they're also there they're down on the
clock
okay we got 74 in here good to see
probably some spillover from the last
last tournament
okay we have a French with a who no we
don't have a French oh yeah I've I've
played this guy before he likes he likes
doing this not sure why
why are you launching all these pawns at
me what did I do to deserve this
why didn't I take that pawn sneaky
let's just be central let's be central
tuck the King away I don't know what
this move is doing exactly
how about we go for the dark squares
right
yeah I don't care if you go hunting this
bishops gonna have a tough time isn't he
let's go for a check here is this not a
problem
um interesting interesting okay called
my bluff way do you see how dangerous
this guy is though I'll take with the
pawn
maybe we form a battery and the and the
B file run
here we go here we go
I was intolerable wasn't he
when a beast oh I had a free night [ __ ]
took that guy
oh I'm way down on the clock
as a check but it's just that
give me some more material
okay takes and then here it's one
exchange oh my god
Clark
they're gonna throw on these checks so
annoying
we're going to have a perpetual
or um oh they did a time burner at the
end that was disgusting that was such a
disgusting game ah man those are ones
that you hate to lose so bad and I hate
to lose that one ah man so frustrating
ah it was beautiful in so many ways and
the result was anything but beautiful ah
how do you recover when that loss is so
painful oh I need to reposition my light
square bishop and it hey what's hits
with tempo so that's nice
I want my bishop here
oh they time Bernhard me too that's what
makes it all the more painful not
supposed to time burn me I'm the only
one who's supposed to time burn ok Queen
takes f6 they were checking me around
like crazy my head is still in that last
game not this one ok I don't know
this poem what's wrong with Bishop here
didn't that one move earlier trap the
Queen
I think it did take twice here hit the
Queen I always do that I am simplifying
and all these moves are just not really
helping me yeah let's just help the
night Oh God
this is a problem okay now I have some
time can I wait upon oh my god look at
the tempos I'm giving my opponent why I
have time uh here I just want the
Queen's off that's all I want
oh okay we got that one other way
the chess wizard is in first I do have
one for okay that was my fifth game
unarmed and I'm in seventh I'm in page
one now okay there's the wizard up there
I see ace is in third okay
metamorphic ax not our first time
playing
let's try Sicilian
okay we'll go for d5 when this isn't
possible now
I guess we'll go here
they moved I didn't realize okay Bishop
f4 I have 95
let's do it boom boom and then a kick
ignoring my shred of the night okay I'll
react to this one Oh
frickin is forgetting I have a that was
an irresponsible that night had a role
yeah oh boy it's going downhill fast
I have a strong night and that's about
it okay um what do I do here nobody
knows I want this in the past pot that's
about it give a check I know you want to
do that okay let's go here yep I knew
that oh my god move I have time I have
time I have time I can't stop laughing
why I guess here I want to get the pun I
got this square covered it's looking
pretty a fork on top of a dollar
opposite color Bishop's can't survive
this
no time watch out here they're the
queens of classic time burner the all
Queen Queen g5 Queen f6 shuffle okay 14
minutes to go this is flying by and the
wizard
no it's not the same wizard as the one
that was playing in the titled arenas
not not a GM there no title for the this
wizard but the wizard is on a tear along
with the 17 others yeah okay I guess
here I should probably go a little
faster how long can we try and maintain
this point we'll grab some space okay
chop guess here there's gonna be a push
let's give them a kick
let's give a check I have something
exciting happening here the exchange but
it is not clear at all this move can be
very strong it's probably very good
let's get out of a that trick put a
knight right here no that bishop is too
strong how do I want to take now
probably the night okaythat's demoted
the brook let's go here this night all
annoying I don't know exactly where I
should be going with the Queen they're
trying to get their Queen involved but
they're there Knight has to go somewhere
I want to offer a queen exchange I'm
down on the clock again okay my queen
should be a bit pesky on g4 hitting the
bishop I'll grab upon her switz check
and a watch for a queen block
my king on the light square here
open it up
I'm on the rook they missed that and
then this is May next cleanest a block
okay they're in a pin all right we got
that 112 with fires where I'm at the
wizard still foot on the gas does Kovac
I believe this is the desk Kovac and
that is in the twitch chat I thought
they're going to take the night okay
so I could take their dark square Bishop
but I'm I prefer to keep this guy right
here okay they could take here because
of this tactic in the end there was an
opportunity for that
let's get ready to why and why am i
running away scared oh I could have
captured twice there in a pin there I
had a second chance
now this guy's pinned let's keep them in
a pin Queen here step up
seems cozy clean on f6 if there's a
check
grab a pawn may in a couple threatened
one to control G one get to this file
oh that's not helping cuz there's a
check and that's me on f2 okay 25:20 17s
bunch of 17s in there just over a
hundred in here now
ten minutes and change alright the ace
is in pause mode
okay David next okay I guess we were
going into French territory
ooh and early capture on D for another
another should I move my knight okay
we're going for mass exchanges and let's
well I should have moved forward as I
approach this square here
here to come
the night it's gonna go no he's going to
take like that I'll take with the pawn
okay I think I know how to win this one
get one rock off that's about it and
then get some as much space as you can
over here and also here
and uh really great moves for for black
then to kind of shuffle you might be
hinting at this advance I don't know my
Knights really strong I'm gonna take
actually a my rook really active
and my king is a better contributor than
theirs in this ending
take and then let's push
here and then these pawns are too fast
way too fast so you give a check and
here no matter what I'm promoting with
checkmate in two threat
and there's the mate
okay back to tournament land the wizard
is still flawless and also in a game
eight and change
okay
let's see
my dude next opponent let's try a four
and angling for a five wanna fight off
this move this is compromised their King
side maybe I should have captured before
the night was played there let's get my
Queen over here
click on Queen side they're going Queen
side gonna launch this at me yeah I
could take I guess I'll be a greedy
player Oh The Inbetweeners
Oh is there gonna be an accident
happening no Queen h4 but this is kind
of scary maybe did I have that move
spending a lot of time here
no no no I want a clean exchange I just
trying to be active here although that's
not really good maybe and maybe I'm okay
with giving the material back yeah I
think I am clean f6o
definitely welcome to that
let's get active now go hunting for that
pond Bishop h6 I guess have to do
something else might as well pivot here
with tempo under 10 keep that pawn
around my knight could use some work
I'll just take there we go this
simplifies and that Bishop is stuck
doing nothing defend over here and then
erase the pawn just get rid the red
keep it squeaky clean no stalemates
there down on time back to tournament
six and change are we going to get a
pairing Ouisa
okay
let's see you'll fork trick it's not
there
let's back up I would love to see this
exchange take with the pawn I'll go this
side too
[Applause]
let's go here
I want to challenge this piece take like
that okay
exchanges I guess in the end we take
like that and like this and just like
that there are no minor pieces around it
this was tempting but I didn't want a
week in this square
I'll take so I now have a pond that's
backward or I control the only open file
okay now their King is more exposed than
mine and I'm more active with mine my um
major pieces in a push yes Queen and
pawn ending I want to keep a rook around
I want my King here also hmm
trysting move weakening my back
I want these two moves and now that I
don't have doubled pawns
stopping a rook d7 so here and then this
even on the clock here and now I'm cozy
very cozy they're trying to get clean
there we're going to grab this product
by go here
oh my god I didn't see that move oh boy
one of these
we have to give some checks who
fortunately I had a it's not over don't
count your chickens too so I was gonna
say fortunately I had a safer King er I
was on move and I was the one to give a
bunch of checks like the game that I
lost earlier my opponent was checking me
around
I just wanted there to be no checks for
a move
it didn't happen like that okay that's a
it's a silly move but I'm still gonna do
it by now
let's take care I don't want to try and
play around play around the plug on e5
okay they're giving me the light square
bishop I guess I'll take it should I've
been a little bit hungry here for the
apon I care more about this no what do I
care about get your King safe
why why am i running into this let's hit
the Queen I am way down on the clock
secure my queen get out of there
Oh the night's gonna go there strong
piece got to challenge it still go here
Knight here takes I wanna get rid of a
knight there are checks should be aware
of that
oh they're giving me a pawn I need a
flight square let's duck with check
flight squares in night here skewers on
tougher the skewer get the Queen's off
this night is really strong Oh allowing
a check d7 37 at the flight square
careful King
careful King I have this if the Queen
moves here check and then check me
there's one check no great follow-up
checks okay here okay how do I win the
night some fast moves in there
just throwing some more checks this
wasn't gonna be mate no I mean there's
check and then I don't know it's
unnecessary to allow any of that okay 41
the wizard is in a game who knows I
don't know what the clock is I have to
try berserk game this is gonna be the
last one so hopefully the wizard loses
and I could get this five point game go
quick now give this punish of this night
a shove
twenty-four seconds it's not a lot just
the clean gown stuff is falling giving
up big squares my king is very weak
very weak oh it's a full rock folks it's
a full rock and this one is not even
going to end
oh oh I got a piece back hang on check
I want the Queen would they resign if
they're if they're losing they have a
bishop here I got the Queen another way
resigned please let's take this
check for seconds they can resign or the
designer they're not a resigner oh the
clock oh I wasn't going to win anyhow
because the clock expired
ailments and I get this final one who
okay The Wizard ended up I guess with
the draw there who
that's gonna do it the wizard 117 and
all the wizard the only one to slow down
the wizard was the last opponent there a
draw 43 36 25 top three confetti land
okay it's been a while since I caught a
a tournament from the
top of the hour the half-hour point
right from the start
while streaming let's see how the pages
to three
peated in this one
all righty some late joiners
clearly
okay to the 116 of you good games all
right enjoyable as usual
you